our next guest is a beloved star beloved
is a word for you of the big screen Anna
Kendrick is known for roles in the Pitch
Perfect and Twilight film franchises as
well as her oscar-nominated performance
in the movie Up in the Air thank you
very much now some critics are already
calling her performance in her new movie
Alice darling her best yet Kendrick
plays a woman who's pushed to her
Breaking Point by her psychologically
abusive boyfriend this is a clip
I can't do another thing wrong Alice how
does that even mean no I lied to him he
doesn't even know that I'm here what I
mean he does now
why did you lie to him
as I'm mad
what
you wouldn't love me if you knew how bad
I am
is that something that he tells you
that's her friend Tess Tess goes Jesus
is that what he tells you that Houston
we have a problem and Kendrick recently
revealed that she Drew from her own
experience when preparing for this role
she's also executive producer of the
film and joins us now this is our first
Broadcast News TV interview about the
movie and we're so glad that you chose
to be here with us that's my pleasure
thank you for having me oh thank you so
much I started watching the movie Anna
and I deliberately didn't know what it
was about sometimes I like to watch with
no thing first I wasn't even sure I
liked her yeah I wasn't sure I liked her
her friends I thought boyfriend was nice
and then Midway you realize that he's a
jerking yeah you were saying that to me
earlier and I I appreciated that so much
I think a lot of people are maybe afraid
to say like I don't really like your
character at first
um why didn't I like her I think that's
important because uh it's you know she's
in a bad place um she's cold she's rude
she's kind of a bummer to be around for
the the first part of the movie and I
think you know we were sort of talking
about the movie feeling like almost like
a mystery film yes because you are going
like wait who is who is likable here who
is the good guy who's the bad guy
because that's the experience so often
is you're going am I the bad guy what's
going on and like you're trying so hard
to pull that apart and figure it out and
you become this detective in your own
life and it's so much harder to figure
out than just looking at like each
behavior and you have to sort of start
try trusting like this is harming me
this is doing a terrible time but that's
really hard to do I also appreciated
that you focused on the psychological
abuse because most of us talk about
physical abuse but very few movies and
very few women talk about the
psychological abuse yeah I meant to hear
that you've been through this yourself
yeah I think what can you share with us
about your own personal experience and
why you wanted to do this yeah I think
um
people don't talk about it is it feels
embarrassing
um uh I think it's it's something that's
so difficult to even put into words and
the challenge of creating a film that
put you in that experience was a really
bold Endeavor I think and the the
screenwriter and and the director Mary
and I did such an incredible job of
really putting you in that experience I
mean as you say like you you start the
movie and you don't really know what's
going on a lot of people have told me
like halfway through the movie that
they're not sure what to believe and
that's and that's a big part of that
experience is that your mind starts to
play tricks on you and you don't know if
you can trust your own perception and
your own experience and the movie kind
of puts you in that place now you've
been through some of these things
personally and now there's a film where
you get to add into it from personal
experience what advice do you give to
someone who might be in a similar
situation I have thought about this so
much because I really wish there was
something I could say I want there to be
something I could say and I'm so
embarrassed to say that I'm not sure
there was anything that I could have
heard that would have like made me
yes I know um and I guess the only thing
that I can say I really I wish I had
something for the people who might be
wondering if they're in this experience
um I mean I think therapy will help a
lot if you can if you have access to it
which I know not everybody does
um but I think if you're the friend of
somebody who's in this situation and
again backstage you were like At first I
wasn't sure if I liked it yes I wasn't
sure I liked your friends it's really
it's a really confusing friendship is a
theme in this film as well absolutely
very much and I think one of the hardest
things for us to do is when we see
someone we love suffering whether that's
with an abusive relationship or
addiction or whatever it is they're
going through we we're so desperate to
help them because we love them that we
want to invade and control and it's so
much harder but it's such a radical Act
of love to go
whatever you decide to do I'm I'm going
to be here for you you know until
obviously you're in a position where
maybe that's harming you but I think
it's interesting too that you use the
word embarrassing because you look at
you you're attractive you're
accomplished you're talented you're
smart did you find yourself wondering
why am I allowing myself to be treated
this way by this person yeah I think
that's the thing that's actually
lingered much longer than the behavior
of the other person is the shame that I
feel around like why didn't how did I
become that person like what did he do
to you Anna I mean we're just talking
about like a really kind of classic
emotional psychological breakdown it was
uh I know that gaslighting has become
this kind of term
um that uh is
um very very popular but it was a really
sustained period And I really didn't
know what to believe anymore I I really
started to wonder if I had a mental
health issue and
um and I yeah I kind of dismantled my
life and for a year I started just going
to therapy and going to Al-Anon and I
was I have this like graveyard of
self-help books in my house that I look
at now and just go like oh man I was
like looking for answers in the wrong
places I was just trying so hard to stop
being crazy I know I always think it's
the worst to doubt yourself don't you
yes when you think God I know I know
what I know yeah it's the worst adult
but when another human being is so
certain that your your nuts basically
it's really difficult to not believe
somebody because I think there's
something about another person's
certainty that makes you go like well I
guess I'm not a hundred percent certain
so it must be me can we ask about Pitch
Perfect sure is there going to be a
Pitch Perfect for Anna Kendrick into the
microphone we all are so obsessed with
each other
um we have this group chat and we're
always hanging out and like we would
love to get paid to
oh my gosh um I I don't know I don't
know that being in charge of your own
French group is a great idea well I know
you're interested in directing you never
know thank you Anna Kendrick thank you
for the movie Alice comma darling
because even that means something
congratulations bravo bravo to you Alice
comma darling because I think that comma
is important because that's him speaking
opens exclusively in an AMC theater
Nationwide on January 20th that's next
Friday we'll be right back